dans le sud-est le temps s'est un peu
stabilisé ce matin et l'aéroport de Nice
fermé depuis 24h maintenant doit
normalement réouvrir demain matin pour
l'instant il faut nettoyer et pomper les
eaux qui ont envahi les sous-sols et
noyer les installations électriques et
informatique Nice Sandra Smith Richard
syvestro une tour de contrôle qui n'a
rien à contrôler en temps normal 200
rotation étent prévu à l'aéroport de
Nice environ 18000 passagers sont privés
d'avion malgré tout certains sont
arrivés à Bonport en bus comme ces
voyageurs qui reviennent de téaviv de
Lyon on nous a embarqué sur un autobus
un autocar qui nous a amené ici et voilà
nos bagages comme vous voyez et puis mon
Dieu on sait pas quoi faire on sait pas
comment rentrer chez nous on a su que
l'aéroport était bloqué mais on savait
pas ni pour combien de temps ni pourquoi
ni comment et la frteure ne s pas du
tout préoccupé de notre de notre
situation à la suite de quoi voilà il
est arrivé ça et vous avez voyagé
combien de temps ben maintenant là euh
ça va faire
28h pour l'instant les accès à
l'aéroport sont interdits à la
circulation mais pas de chômage
technique tout le personnel est mobilisé
il faut réparer l'électronique noyée
dans les deux terminaux pour être prêt à
repartir demain on peut dire maintenant
certainement puisque ça fait 2 jours et
de nuit que les personnes travaillent
que ça réouvre demain
avec un programme normal une cellule de
crise a été mise en place le numéro du
Standard est à nouveau opérationnel mais
les dégâts vont se chiffrer en dizaines
de millions de francs voitures sinistré
ou bagages perdus les particuliers vont
aussi se retourner contre l'aéroport par
l'intermédiaire de leur compagnie
d'assurance le redécollage économique
s'annonce laborieux à Nice